Welcome back, everyone
It's Charlie.
This will be my Ant-Man and the Wasp
Quantumania Post-Credits Scene Video.
There were two Post-Credits scenes.
There's so many Easter eggs,
so many references, a bunch of teasers for
what's going to be happening in Avengers
five, Qing Dynasty in Secret Wars.
It's also directly connected to Loki.
Season two.
I will be doing episode videos
for all that.
Be sure to subscribe to get them all.
You may have even spotted the Doctor Doom
version of Kang, which I'll explain.
Careful for spoilers for the movie
if you haven't seen it yet,
but at the end of the movie,
Kang tries to activate his time ship
and take his entire city,
which is a version of principles from
the comics back to the normal multiverse.
They confirmed the Council of Kang's, or,
as he called them, the dynasty of Kang's
big Avengers.
Qing Dynasty reference
exiled him to the quantum realm
because it exists separately
from the normal flow of space time.
It exists the same way
the TVA exists and the Council of Kang.
Just like outside, separated
from the normal timeline,
they literally separated him
from time itself because he disagreed
with the rest of the Kang variants
about how to govern the multiverse
and probably governed
the Council of Kang's.
He is meant to be the Kang
who started the original multiverse war.
He makes a bunch of references to knowing
how everything ends, how time ends.
That's both a reference to the events
of the Loki series and Avengers
five Qing Dynasty In Avengers
six Secret Wars with all the incursions.
He very specifically references
the word incursions.
Ant-Man and the Wasp
seemingly kill him by getting him
sucked into his Multiversal engine.
Marvel
really wants you to think that he's dead
because in the first Post-Credits
scene, the Scarlet Centurion
Kang says that he's certain that he died.
He wouldn't
have called all the other Kang variants
if he didn't think that he was dead.
And I don't think that Marvel is lying
to us here.
But at the very end of the movie,
it says Kang will return.
It's mostly meant to be a reference
to the Council of Kangs
in that every Kang will return.
This is a funny montage when everyone
goes back to Earth and Ant-Man
suddenly remembers that Kang had told him
that everyone would die,
like everyone in the multiverse would die
if he didn't get out and that he wanted
to prevent a coming calamity.
That's meant to be the ending
that he told Janet Van Dyne about.
I've seen how it all ends.
He was referencing Qing Dynasty
in secret wars with his animated 3D model
of all the timelines breaking
into each other, destroying each other.
That's a reference to the incursions
from the time
runs out storyline in the comics
and the incursions that Reed Richards
told Doctor Strange
about in Multiverse of Madness.
Clea also told him to during
the Post-Credits scene for that movie.
The larger the footprint you leave behind,
the greater the risk of an incursion.
You caused an incursion,
and we're going to fix it.
They have the funny moment
where ant-man's like, Well, you know what?
Nothing bad is going to happen.
There's nothing to worry about.
Whatever.
And just moves on with his life like it's
no big deal when clearly it is
something really bad is about to happen
and that something really bad
is going to happen in Avengers
five Qing Dynasty,
because right after that
in the Mid-Credits scene
we see the actual Council of Kang's,
but because of what Kang called them, Kang
the Conqueror, their true name in
the MCU is the dynasty of kangs,
which means that in Avengers five, Qing
Dynasty, it's
basically going to be the new Avengers
versus the Council of Kangs
fighting a bunch of Kang variants
like you thought fighting
one of them was bad.
Wait till you fight thousands of them.
It starts on a wide shot of an arena
where they hold their council meetings
and all of them are teleporting in
and this is important.
Notice how all their portals look exactly
the same color and shape and design
as Reed Richards Fantastic four Portal
in Doctor Strange Multiverse of Madness.
Kang in the comics is meant to be related
to Reed Richards biologically, also
to Doctor Doom like it's meant to be
a big question mark and kind of ambiguous.
Like we think that they're related
because he's name Nathaniel Richards
in all the timelines where he rises up
once each Kang variant in their timelines
takes power,
though they usually change their name
to something else
during the flashbacks in the movie,
before Janet learns that he is
Kang the Conqueror.
He calls himself Nathaniel Richards.
They paint up a giant statue of Kang
the Conqueror that just died
looking down on the council.
I think they're implying
that he used to be
one of the rulers of the council
with the other three that we see first.
One of the most powerful variants
he probably disagreed
with, then went off the rails,
sort of destroying other timelines
against their wishes,
and they ganged up to exile him.
You hear the voiceover
coming from the Scarlet Centurion Kang,
calling him the exiled one.
As the camera pans up,
his armor is purple instead of red,
but the armor designs
look similar to Scarlet Centurion.
That was a Kang
that was inspired by Doctor Doom
to create a persona that was like Dr.
Doom's.
There is a doctor Doom version of Kang,
but that's something completely different.
Remember Doctor Doom also supposed
to be related to Kang distantly?
He argues next with the Rama,
talking about them
being upset
that they weren't the ones to kill him in.
There was a rama to Easter Egg
during the Moon Knight series
and in the comics, Rama
was the first persona that Kang took,
the first time travel mission.
He found the plans for Dr.
Doom's time travel platform
in a Doctor Doom museum, recreated it
using 30th century technology,
then traveled to ancient Egypt
and called himself Rama Tut.
It was actually the Fantastic
Four that found out about it
and kicked him back to the future.
Then Immortus walks in,
and even though I always thought he
who remains
was meant to be based on the Immortus
version of Kang mixed with
he remains from the comics.
This one looks exactly like comic book of.
He is meant to be
the oldest version of Kang,
which is why he sounded kind of raspy
when they were talking to each other.
Technically,
he remains was the oldest version
that we just saw during Loki season one,
but he was killed by Sylvie,
so he isn't around.
During the second rebooted multiverse,
making Immortus the oldest version.
He's also technically supposed
to be the most powerful.
When Immortus says they killed him
and they're beginning
to touch the multiverse, this window
opens, showing all the arcane timelines
like we saw at the end of Loki season one,
and those others,
quote unquote, threaten to take everything
the dynasty of kangs have built.
They have to stop them.
They're referring to the Avengers,
but the Avengers
from every different universe.
So this whole Post-Credits
scene is just generally meant
to be Marvel's new version of the Thanos
scene at the end of the first Avengers
movie, Teasing the Infinity Gantlet,
Avengers Infinity War, Avengers Endgame,
meaning Avengers
five, Qing Dynasty and Secret Wars
are going to be The Avengers
in other Multiverse Avengers like
Wolverine, Fox, X-Men Fox Fantastic Four.
Tobey Maguire. Spider-Man.
Andrew Garfield. Spider-Man.
Coming Back, Everyone Fighting the Council
of Kangs Fighting the Dynasty of Kangs.
The Avengers. Kang Dynasty.
Then they show a wide shot
of all the other kangs palling in
with some close ups
to show you some specific versions
from the comics,
some of the more notable versions.
And it's meant to end on this comic book
panel exactly like it looks exactly
like this, even with the same messed up
face of that last kang Looking at
As far as I know, there's only about 38
different versions of Kang in the comics,
but they're meant to be thousands
inside the council chamber here.
So what they're saying
and you probably saw this,
some of them are meant to look almost
exactly like some of the other versions.
Some of them are very similar to others.
The general idea, though, is that a lot of
them are less powerful than others.
And that's why these three seem
like they rule.
The council because they're meant to be
the most powerful versions.
Right before that last wide shot,
with all the ones portraying in
we already know about six of them so far.
There's Kang the Conqueror that we just
saw get sucked into the time engine.
We also previously saw He who
Remains and Mr.
Griffin Kang During Loki season one, Mr.
Gryffin was the variant of Kang,
who went to the present to establish QENG
Enterprises, Q E N G,
which took over the Avengers tower,
but he was pruned
during the events of Loki Season one.
A couple of the ones that portal in looks
similar to he who remains
wearing these flowing robes,
and Kang the Conqueror, who we just saw
get sucked into the time engine.
This one on the left
is actually a real big one because notice
his armor looks a lot like Dr.
Doom's.
I believe that's
meant to be the variant of Kang pretending
to be Doctor Doom in the comics.
That's as close as we've actually seen
to an MCU version of Doctor Doom
actually showing up on screen.
There is a version of Kang
called Do the Annihilating Conquer,
but that's sort of like a reverse idea,
like Dr.
Doom becoming this sort of amalgam version
of Kang with a bunch of extra powers.
There's even a Galactus version of Kang
called The Time Eater.
That looks kind of like Galactus floating
head, just perverted to look a little bit
more like Kang said.
I know some of you had questions
about the crazier looking versions,
like there's a lizard version of Kang
He just called Reptilian Kang.
There's a bunch of them that sit together
with orange suits that look like
less powerful versions of Kang,
but not that different.
And then it ends on the really messed up
looking face version of Kang,
which is meant to be
right out of the comics here.
Like it's meant to be this exact panel
that it ends on.
I think that might be Kronos Tut,
who is just another member of the council
in the comics.
I didn't see these other major versions,
but I'm sure at some point
they'll pop up somewhere in the MCU.
So there's the Iron Lad version of Kang,
which is basically just a child
version of the character pretending to be
Iron Lad based on Iron Man.
There's Kid Immortus
is There's even a Kamala Kang and
a version of Kang who is Susan Storm
from an alternate universe.
So like all these weird different versions
pretending to be other people,
it's always possible they could pop up
in, like, secretly be Kang in disguise.
But in the second Post-Credits scene,
it starts in the late 1800s.
It's meant to be around the same time
period as Thomas Edison
and Nicholas Tesla
arguing about DC versus AC current,
but it's the Victor timely variant of Kang
Giving a presentation for a small theater
audience about controlling time
the same way that Thomas Edison or Nikola
Tesla
would talk about controlling electricity.
His banner reads Victor timely
and his astounding temporal marvel
as in Marvel Comics.
And it seems like he's showing off
a primitive time
travel device using old timey technology.
And he's basically pitching the audience
about controlling time,
which is what all the Kang
variants are doing or trying to do.
He says. Time is everything.
It shapes our lives,
but perhaps we can shape it.
Then they reveal in the crowd
Loki and Mobius are
they are on a day assignment with Loki,
just deadly afraid of him
in trying to convince Mobius
what a threat Kang Variants are like.
That's in.
That's the guy
I've been telling you about in Mobius.
Not really understanding
why he's so dangerous
because he's from the rebooted timeline.
It has no memories
from the events of Loki Season one,
and this is just generally meant
to tease the events of Loki Season two,
which will air in the summer.
I think, after Secret Invasion.
And I think the idea here
is that a version of Kang
just went back into the past in the late
1800s and is trying to change history
from this point in the past.
In part of Loki, Season two will be
then trying to stop Kang variants in him,
trying to convince them about the dangers
of the Kang Multiverse war
and what's really going on
with the Council of Kang's
while they're also going on day to day
missions trying to stop regular
nexus events
like the TVA would normally be doing.
Like that's
still going on in the background too.
While the stuff with the Kang Multiverse
War and the Council of Kang's is going on,
I'm sure there's going to be a thousand
more questions.
I've got a bunch of bonus videos planned.
My next big one will be my full breakdown
of the movie Easter Eggs for Everything.
So be sure to enable alerts
from my channel so you don't miss that.
That should be up Saturday morning.
Everyone click here for that
full breakdown
and Easter eggs for the entire movie.
I'll update the link as soon as I post
that and click here for my Loki Season 2
trailer video.
Thank you so much for watching.
Everyone stay safe
and I'll see you guys in the next one.